justice on y viendra dans un instant à
cette étude
d'abord on va parler de ce procès sans
précédent
on l'a déjà beaucoup dit qui s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à lyon car c'est la
troisième fois que patrick dils affronte
la cour d'assises pour le meurtre de
deux enfants tués à coups de pierres il
ya plus de quinze ans le premier procès
avait eu lieu en 89
le deuxième après une demande de
révision en 2001 et grâce à la nouvelle
loi sur l'appel en cour d'assises
patrick dils peut être à nouveau tenté
de s'expliquer sur place première
journée d'audience dominique verdeilhan
fanny auvergne je ne connais rien de la
vie à 31 ans patrick dils est déjà un
vieux prisonnier il a passé la moitié de
sa vie en prison pour la troisième fois
en 13 ans il se raconte face à une cour
d'assises dès mineurs
une enfance sans problème avec des
parents aimants un cap2 cuisinier qui le
satisfait amplement patrick dils parle
avec abondance il se reconnaît naïf trop
gentil mais ce troisième procès public
alors ses avocats en vol plus
tout doit être dit même le pire dils
avoue avoir été violés en prison j'ai
l'impression d'être sale dit il il n'a
plus rien à cacher plus rien à perdre
il est mort dans répond du tac au tac
aux avocats des parties civiles avec la
bénédiction de ses conseils on l'a senti
à une ou deux reprises un peu agressif
assez bien je souhaite qu'il a carte
blanche peut être aussi agressif qu'il
le ferait il peut taper du poing peut
faire ce qu'il veut la carte blanche la
porte sa défense cette publicité des
débats at elle libéré la parole de
patrick dils tous ceux qui étaient
présents au second procès à reims le
reconnaissent mais question cette
apparente décontraction et cette
pugnacité seront elles toujours présente
lors de l'examen des faits